we're taking a look at the biggest and
baddest Marvel baddies to find out
what's really driving them in their
quest for world domination from
genocidal warlords to high-tech thieves
here's what these MCU villains can't
live without loki is certainly a menace
capable of great destruction he invited
killer frost giants to throw his
coronation he teamed up with the
Chitauri stole the space stone and used
the mind stone to wreak havoc on New
York City and at any given moment
there's a good chance he'll try to stab
you in the back when you're not looking
but even when he impersonated Odin and
ruled Asgard for a while Loki wasn't
really interested in elaborate evil
schemes not really he mostly just liked
a really good prank loki is driven by
chaos in addition to the whole you know
wanting to be king thing all this
because loki desires that's wrong it is
my birthright your birthright
what's Tut died he just can't help
himself even when he sometimes tries to
do the right thing once a car Loki was
more than happy to serve the Grand
Master in Thor Ragnarok and he cheered
when the Hulk smacked him around in the
arena he later tried to portray Thor
when they were teaming up but eventually
the god of mischief did the right thing
and help defeat hella and as God but
that just speaks to the guy's
unpredictability even when going up
against Thanos Loki offered him his
fealty and then tried to stab him he got
killed for his audacity as Thanos isn't
one who really cares much for jokes
happily thanks to the events of Avengers
in game there's a version of Loki
running around in time undoubtedly
causing all sorts of trouble Johann
Schmidt the Red Skull was one of
Hitler's right-hand men during World War
two as depicted in Captain America the
First Avenger he formed his own offshoot
of the Nazi SS called Hydra and was
obsessed by dr. Abraham Erskine Super
Soldier Serum consumed with becoming the
superior man so that he could rightfully
wield the tesseract Schmidt forced
Earth's kind to give him the formula the
earlier version of the serum without the
addition of the crucial vital race gave
Schmidt all of the power he desired but
it also had a hideous side effect it
disfigured his face literally
turning him into well a red skull it
didn't matter much to Schmidt who didn't
care about the superficial Aryan ideal
he just wanted to make himself into
something new so he could use the power
of the Norse gods via the tesseract
that's why the existence of his American
opposite Captain America enraged him and
defeating cap was imperative to prove
his superiority
unfortunately for o'schmidt when he
accidentally touched the tesseract with
his bare hands it activated and sent him
halfway across the universe through a
wormhole the tesseract also known as the
space stone sent him to vermeer to be
the whispy guardian of the soul stone so
much for the superior man Ultron was
initially designed by Tony Stark in
Avengers age of Ultron as a suit of
armor for the world Tony wanted the AI
to be a defense system to protect the
earth against aliens and
interdimensional menaces but he
inadvertently gave it true sentience and
more than a touch of his megalomaniacal
personality with the aid of the mind
stone which proves that using the
Infinity stones for any reason just a
certified bad idea upon reviewing the
carnage surrounding the Avengers and the
damaged humanity and flex on itself in
general
Ultron immediately came to the
conclusion that the best way to protect
the world was to destroy well everybody
the thing is in his twisted mind he
interpreted this idea as well just take
a gander is that what you've come to end
the Avengers I've come to save the world
but also yeah being an advanced being he
attempted his mission in the most
efficient way he could think of trying
to recreate the extinction level event
that wiped out the dinosaurs by ripping
up a huge section of sokovia and
smashing it into the ground like a
meteor no more humans
Ultron wanted a brand new earth built in
his own image creating a machine Age
founded on his own twisted vision of
natural selection to him humanity was
just a bad idea that needed to be wiped
out in favor of better forms of life
like himself he never did quite
understand how much of his personality
was driven by Tony Stark's own ambitions
Albia dwarfed almost beyond recognition
of all the MCU villains none were quite
as obsessed with their goals as Helmut
Zemo a sokovia internal and leader of a
covert hit squad Zemo lived a happy life
with his wife and avenges obsessed son
Karl then Ultron came along and killed
thousands of sokovia --nz including
zimos wife son and father as a result
Zemo blame the Avengers for not caring
about the lives of innocents and he
vowed to destroy them
Zemo knew he couldn't kill the Avengers
himself but he studied them learn their
secrets and manipulated them into almost
destroying each other as seen in Captain
America Civil War he framed Bucky Barnes
for the death of two chaka the black
pants his father then using Bucky as a
pawn
he manipulated Captain America and Iron
Man into a confrontation that nearly
killed them both leaving The Avengers
fractured four years Zemo is unique
because this life was basically over the
only thing he thought about after the
murder of his family was this idea of
obtaining some kind of justice for their
senseless deaths he had no other goals
and justice wasn't even something he
enjoyed he simply felt it was his duty
to destroy the Avengers in the name of
his family in fact he was about to kill
himself listening to a voice mail from
his wife one last time before black
panthers stopped him and captured him as
an ancient god like celestial ego the
Living Planet flickered into existence
and slowly coalesced the planet around
himself desperately lonely he created a
humanoid form and used that to travel
around the universe soon after he
decided to terraform
every planet he visited into an
extension of himself as part of a plan
he called the expansion his Universal
legacy would literally be himself on
every planet everything would be him a
perfect plan for a narcissistic God
covering all that exists until
everything is
of course he needed a power boost in
order to make it work which is why he
impregnated countless women of numerous
species
he hired yondu to bring their children
to him so he could see if they inherited
his powers none of them did so he simply
killed them then he finally found Peter
quill and brought him to his world as
seen in guardians of the galaxy vol 2
ego full quo with what seemed to be the
fatherly love Poole had always wanted
but ego was simply after his sons power
to make the expansion work fortunately
quills friends helped him fight back and
they destroyed Eagles in a core saving
the universe and ending Eagles plan for
a long lasting legacy and his life if
ego could have thought of anything
beyond his own existence he'd still be
alive
the Grandmaster is one of the oldest
beings in the universe with only his
brother the collector being as equal
like the collector the Grandmaster has a
very specific obsession he loves to be
entertained upon arriving on the planet
sakaar the Grandmaster established
himself as the ruler of this junction of
wormholes that brought stragglers and
lost souls to him on a constant basis he
quickly had the idea of pitting the new
arrivals against each other in a
gladiatorial combat based on the statues
of former champions the Grandmaster at
one point captured the likes of beta ray
bill the man thing the BI beast and
Aries of course the Hulk was his
favorite champion entertaining him
endlessly until Thor came along to spoil
all of his fun still the lives of others
were far less important than his own
good time
when you're that old it's easy to get
bored of course with his obedience disk
melt stick and loyal warriors it was
hard to protest when he rigged the games
in his own favor thankfully for the
people of Saqqara
Thor helped lead a revolt against the
Grandmaster resulting in a confrontation
with a very angry populace hey at least
he won't be bored while his ex subjects
try to tear him apart this revolution
has been a huge success
yay us pat on the back pat on the back
come on no Erik kill monger Stevens with
the Sun Oven Joe boo the brother of King
takaka of Wakanda enjoyable was sent to
America as an
to cover observer and he learned that
black people in America were quote
overly policed and incarcerated and
subjected to poverty and misery so he
planned the fight back by stealing
wakanda's vibranium and leading a
worldwide revolt when takaka learned of
his plans he confronted an Jobu and soon
after the wakandan prince was dead -
Chaka then left and Jobos corpse behind
in America as well as his son Eric in
other words the King had abandoned his
nephew moments later Eric found his
dad's lifeless body and obsessively
vowed to take what was his not only for
himself but for all the world's black
people kill manga wanted reparations for
what he had lost his father his
childhood and justice for his people
we're gonna send by brainian weapons out
to our war dogs they'll arm oppressed
people all over the world so they can
finally rise up and kill those in power
so he joined the Navy SEALs and became a
deadly marksman earning the kill manga
nickname and he acquired the skills and
training to kill his cousin the new king
T'Challa
kill manga desired for Wakanda - stop
hiding and to take his true role as
leader Liberator and subjugated and he
planned on claiming the throne by
killing T'Challa in ritual combat of
course the black panther eventually took
back control of his crown and defeated
KO manga but he also heated his cousin's
lessons and peacefully opened Wakanda up
to the world times of crisis no waifu -
beauteous Thanos the architect of so
much destruction simply wanted balance
growing up on Titan he quickly realized
that his home was like most planets with
quote too many mouths to feed and not
enough to go around
thus he proposed an idea if they kill
off half the population at random they'd
in all likelihood save the other half
makes sense on paper right well he ended
up being banished from Titan as a result
of his outrageous idea which worked out
for him at least it turns out that he
was proven right the population of Titan
died out vanos then took his quest
across the universe building a host of
fanatically devoted followers who
conquered and obliterated half of the
population on countless worlds but for
Thanos this method was too slow so he
sought out the infinite
nice tones he was so certain of his
radical objective that he plan to wipe
out half of all life in the universe
with a single snap of his fingers with
all six domes I could simply snap my
fingers they would all cease to exist
and I call that you see as seen in
Avengers infinity war Thanos did just
this in his mind he was doing what
needed to be done to do any less would
be a failure of will one that put the
entire universe in peril of course his
single-minded obsession didn't concern
itself with what happened after nor did
it otherwise try to improve any lives
Quinton Beck was a former engineer for
Stark Industries who developed
sophisticated hologram technology Tony
Stark took his tech gave it a silly
acronym binary augmented retro framing
or barf and used it for his own
therapeutic purposes when Bette
complained stock fired him partly
because he was unstable stock wasn't
wrong but it was still a pretty crappy
thing to do Beck in many of the
disgruntled stock employees bided their
time and formed a plan for revenge as
seen in spider-man far from home it
wasn't just revenge on stock personally
as he died stopping vanos it was revenge
on Starks and legacy Beck learned that
Stark had left Peter Parker a pair of
sunglasses that control Edythe a global
satellite and computer hacking system
that controlled a huge weapons Network
Beck wanted those glasses so that he
could be the biggest baddest best hero
of them all
better than Iron Man and Beck almost
achieved his dream as he manipulated
Peter into handing over the glasses
through a campaign of smoke and mirrors
or rather drones and Holograms
eventually Peter figured out Beck's plan
and wouldn't rest until he rectified his
error as a result Spiderman utterly
defeated Mysterio but as he was dying
the villain got his revenge on Peter too
he framed him for the attacks on London
and then revealed his secret identity to
the world making Peter a fugitive
Peter Parker talked about being one
bitter baddie check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
Lucca videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]